my uh manager had kind of always said
we just need that one piece of work phil
she's that one thing
you know that we can really shout about
how has origins changed your life oh
that's a big question um
it has changed in terms of
um
personally you know i
the film has um
brought that hunger back you know
that maybe was um
becoming a little bit tired to all the
frustrations of making film and doing it
for so long and not
quite getting there wherever there is
you know
and now i feel revitalized and refreshed
and just kind of
you know reborn in a way uh
in terms of wow if we can pull that off
then actually we can make some really
cool stuff
um and i feel like i've finally made
something that
is is very me which i know is a weird
thing to say when you're kind of
ripping off existing films and things
but
um hopefully still has some of my
personality and my perspective
you know in that film it's not just a
shop for shop rip-off of
you know things that we love um and
um i think what has changed is
um opening the doors
so i was lucky to already have a manager
you know a wonderful manager in in l.a
so i
i always had a certain amount of access
to you know to to people but my
uh manager had kind of always said
we just need that one piece of work phil
she's that one thing
you know that we can really shout about
and maybe it's a commercial maybe it's a
short maybe it's one of these features
maybe it's something but
you know you you so i've made all this
stuff but i hadn't quite
had something that we could bet the
houses on you know
and i was for years in our relationship
you know uh with my manager um
uh it has always been what is that thing
and suddenly that
this is that thing you know this is
definitely that thing that we send out
and then to send that out and have you
know
sit down with you know be invited to
amblin you know and sit down there and
have conversations with those guys about
films and
films i want to make and and just
suddenly it's like it's like mecca right
it's like going it's like being back
at the heart of everything that you love
you know
that was very special um and
just now um i feel that
um i have a piece of work that
you know raises the eyebrow enough for
people to want to pick up that phone to
want to read that script
and want to kind of so you know so i
think
um you know it's it's been a little bit
frustrating with kovid
and the industry and we all know what's
been happening uh
depending on when you're watching this
but you know we all uh
everything is a little bit up in the air
at the moment
so it's very hard to get new things off
the ground um
but um but hopefully it's a film that
lasts
and and i can it will go on
um to uh allow me to
talk to interesting people i mean the
thing is is like without that film i
never would have sat down on ambly and
never would have sat down with some
producers who
you know like heroes of mine that made
films i love
you know and actually have genuine
conversations about
um the kind of things that we want to
make
you know those would have never happened
so
so it's already kind of inverted cards
paying off
in that way as an introduction you know
am i directing the next jurassic world
five
exclusive no i'm not yet
but um at least hopefully it's some
proof that i could if i had the
opportunity
um and and who knows what's around the
corner
who knows who's watching it right now
you know people
uh seem to keep discovering it all the
time and
there's a few people i can't mention who
have seen it
that i'm like wow that's
like how the hell have you seen this
film it's amazing they you know
take that's the beauty of the internet
and youtube and putting yourself out
there that these things take a life of
their own and people
share it and you know and you never know
what desk
that it's gonna arrive on and that's
kind of it that's really exciting now is
to
kind of think what is what's possible
next you know
um on that journey to being the
the hollywood director inverted commerce
which i you know wanted to do since i
was
eight you know well in that vein how
confident
are you that you'll be hired to direct a
hollywood movie
in the next few years let's say covid
somehow however it's going to work
itself out if it does hopefully
uh how do you envision yourself
working as a hollywood director
i mean yes i mean i've always kind of
pictured myself doing it from from the
beginning but
now i feel that i have a piece of work
that maybe
[Music]
i don't know alleviates fears or
reservations or anything like that it's
like okay well if you can do that
film then maybe you can do this film
um and um uh
you know and that's that's very exciting
and yeah i mean 100
i hope i am in the next few years and
based on
you know a few conversations that are
happening at the moment
obviously being a bit stored and
difficult because of covid but
if any one of these things happen then
you know that's that'll happen
uh very quickly i realize i'm probably
shooting myself in the foot by saying
it's out loud on youtube right now
so i can eat my words in 10 years and
i'm like oh phil
what were you thinking but you've got
you've just
you've got to be positive right you've
got to be optimistic about it
um because there's already so many knows
and negativity and
and um and difficult things to navigate
to kind of get to wherever that is you
want to be
and if you don't sort of believe in what
you're doing
um then that's then that makes the whole
thing even worse
so yeah um i mean i feel like i've
already put money on it
because you know it cost a lot of money
to make origins
so uh you know i feel like i've already
placed my bet
so whether that hopefully pays off we
will we will see but
yeah i hope so i hope so if hollywood
doesn't happen
can you still make a living as an
independent filmmaker
if the hollywood dream doesn't happen
then now i can
like wholeheartedly say well i tried you
know i mean like i
like there isn't another short film
you know there isn't like another
version of origins that you would make
right you just put your store out there
you put everything into it and you go
there you go and you hope
that maybe things come back you just
gotta put it all out there
um and you know one of the reasons
for taking that risk in making the film
financially and professionally
um because you know if you make the
column and column b
of like reasons to make it reason not
make it the reason not to make it is way
bigger
on paper than it is to make it um
from practice practical perspectives but
it's
um but i also thought like you know what
if i don't make it i don't try i'll
always regret it
um and and i don't i don't i felt like
i could i could probably live with
like the kind of hollywood dream to
inverted commerce
to not happen having tried then always
wondering well what if i did make that
film
you know because um
you know this it's still a very
rewarding experience right from the
things i've talked about in terms of the
comments and the connections to people
and
people over the world watching it and
that's what you make films for right
of course you don't really set out to
self-finance the films and also
not be allowed to actually profit from
them because obviously it's not your ip
like it's lucasfilm disney's ap so you
can't even
you know generate any income from it
so um but it's
but yeah you know i've still got ideas
and still ways of making independent
film and i i don't think it's all
reliant on doing the big studio deal
but i feel that i feel that i'm sort of
done making
really low budget like films
you know um because i feel like i've
sort of done that and kind of
got the t-shirt you know uh unless it
was something
you know script that was beautifully
interesting or again ambitious and
challenging
then i would then then that would be
great to do
um but yeah i feel
uh i i i feel like i'm going around the
houses with this answer because i'm not
actually
maybe articulate i've said it out loud
it's the first time i'm thinking about
it properly but
um genuinely i'm like um it would
obviously be frustrating because i've
always wanted to make those big huge
films
but it is like winning the lottery and
then some but
but yeah i wouldn't have any regrets now
having made it
you know because i'm still gonna carry
on making films
right whatever films they are i don't
know but at least i've
sort of scratched that itch by making
origins
to this sort of scale ambition the way
we have done
do you wish feature films paid as well
as commercials
yeah i mean it'd be great if like
low-budget independent film paid
as much as commercials um
yeah i mean i'm very lucky to um you
know
make commercials and be busy making
commercials such one
and um and you know i've been doing that
now for
15 years uh i directed my first paid
commercial was 20.
um so uh i
um so yeah i've been doing it quite a
long time and surviving
doing it so far
and yes it'd be great i mean you know
when you get into the big tent pole side
of thing
with with big risk and big budget
becomes you know
a bigger upside of you know bigger
salaries for directors and stuff
at that level so they would probably you
know
or they would uh dwarf a commercial fee
um but it's a hard life i mean it's
and on all the indie features i've made
i've still made commercials because i
i put everything on the screen really i
just paid myself
you know or was paid a small amount
um because i was like well no let's get
that thing let's
let's get an extra day you know whatever
that thing is at that moment it's all
about making the film and commercials
i've enabled that because i'm busy and
that's how i make my living
um i i mean i don't know how like
full-time indie producers survive like
it's
that's a hard life getting a paycheck
every x out of years when you make
something i
may i don't know how that i don't know
how they do that i don't know
but people do it so um so i guess i'm
lucky with the commercials
i mean dakota's safety net is making it
sound very reliable but
again things can change look at covid
look at lockdowns look at
the industry you know things can change
like that so i'm just lucky that
um that i have that currently
you